discovering your Y is just the beginning
I'm putting this out in the world why
you gotta ask yourself why
what's up believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn or
the most common rules that successful
people follow find your Y also if you
want to know a Gary Vee David Goggin
Simon sonic and others have to say about
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence - like
the join is in the description below the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
you will never learned from people if we
always tap-dance around the truth even
though I'm gonna sell you the most
beautiful hammer I'm not gonna guarantee
the instructional integrity of the house
[Music]
people put all the time because they're
doing it for money I think the bigger
question is what do you want the money
for is it blocking and insecurities have
to get the girl is it is it is because
you're trying to mass as much as you can
because you don't actually don't like
working and you want to live the reason
so many people's to fail in life and
business is their model is let me get
the money so that I can enjoy and relax
they think of it it's like hoarding it
and then eating it all over time so our
retirement and all this and it's such a
bad way to them because then you're
feeling the pressure of like massing so
that you can then enjoy I think the
bigger question is like what do you up
to like why are you doing it like what's
up I just think a lot of people are
trying to achieve success and use fame
or money as makeup for
a situation that they're just not happy
about like you have to figure out how to
make your day in and day out happy my
biggest advice to give everybody in the
world is like I say we live in an
external world everything is is you got
to see it touch it as it's external if
you can for the rest of your life live
inside of yourself stop listening to
people who are calling you fat gay
transsexual [ __ ] everything that is
makes no sense
all these insecure people putting their
insecurities on you you got to flush it
out you got to just be whoever the hell
God or whatever the hell you believe in
if you believe in nothing but yourself I
don't care what it is you're gonna take
everything and throw it away you have to
believe in one thing and that is
yourself and and I'm not saying don't
believe in God are what you believe in
but right now for you to find greatness
in yourself you're not gonna find it by
looking in a book or by even hearing me
I may give you the spark but you've got
to go inside yourself to find it and
that means you gotta be quiet shut the
[ __ ] up go in a room stop talking search
your soul search your mind search your
abilities and you'll find it but if
you're not looking for it you won't find
it so you got to go start your journey
and the journey starts with you finding
why the hell am I here on this planet
Earth why am I here if you don't know
that you will live the rest your life
searching always asking the question why
discovering your Y is just the beginning
in order to enjoy all the benefits of
having a clearly articulated Y you'll
need to have the courage and discipline
to use it like Thomas Edison said vision
with that execution is hallucination
there is an ideal order for implementing
your Y though sometimes reality does get
in the way and it all starts with you
our natural tendency is to start with
the tangible we define our value by what
we do so it takes practice to start with
Y like riding a bicycle at first we're
unsure unsteady we're in our heads
thinking about all the things we need to
do pedal fast keep enough speed so we
don't fall over
we have to really concentrate we may
even fall over even scrape our knees but
we get back on the bike and try again
and eventually it becomes natural
starting with why is no different at
first it feels awkward it may not even
work but with practice it will become so
natural that you won't even be able to
imagine a time when you couldn't do it
just like riding a bicycle in time your
Y will act as a filter for many of the
decisions and choices you make it
becomes a tool to help you find a job or
seize an opportunity in which you're
more likely to succeed it removes a lot
of the guessing here's a metaphor to
show you what I mean it's called the
celery test we're constantly asking
people for their advice on what to do or
how to do it it's like going to a dinner
party and somebody says do you know what
you need you need M&Ms we've done so
well with M&Ms you've got to use M&Ms
somebody else says to us rice milk in
this economy you have to use rice milk
someone else says to us Kit Kats you
have to use Kit Kats and somebody else
says to you it's all about celery we go
to the supermarket with all this good
advice from all these smart people with
brilliant case studies and we buy
everything we've I'd kick cats and M&Ms
celery and rice milk there's a lot of
time we spend at the supermarket and a
lot of money we spend at the supermarket
and when we get to the checkout line
we're standing there with all these
products in our hands and no one can see
what we believe because we bought
everything but let's imagine we know our
why let's imagine our wise to always be
healthy and only do things that protect
the health of our bodies
now which products do we buy given all
the same advice from all the same smart
people this time we only buy celery and
we only buy rice milk they're the only
two that makes sense we spend less time
and less money at the supermarket and
when we're standing there in line with
only celery and only rice milk now
people can see what we believe somebody
walking past can say hey I can see that
you're healthy so am I you just
attracted an opportunity or a referral
or a friend simply by saying and doing
the things that you believe and the best
part is its scalable as soon as I said
the Y you knew
Zack Lee which products we were going to
buy this means the more you can
articulate your why the more others will
know what you stand for and will be able
to help you make the right decisions
from now on you will work to ensure
everything you do is a good fit if you
do too many things that aren't a good
fit
you'll feel uncomfortable and people
will feel that you're being inauthentic
on the other hand when you start with
why your ability to stand out find
support and work to all your natural
strengths will flourish with practice
you will learn to trust your Y you will
eventually start to see your job and the
things you do as ways to breathe life
into your cause and the better you get
at it the more you will feel that your
life and everything you do has purpose
the best way to implement your Y is to
work in it slowly you don't have to do
all the tips we suggest what is
important is that you pick up to 3 and
commit to practicing and using them now
I think most people they don't get what
they want in life because they don't
know what they want
so they lack clarity
and why the elect mullah Dacian chances
are they haven't suffered a lot of pain
you can see now are we on a private jet
I remember
many years ago when I was struggling in
business couldn't pay the bills
my father had his first stroke and I was
so much in debt and I couldn't even
afford the plane ticket he was in the
hospital he was an emergency and I
couldn't afford even to buy an economy
ticket because I was in Canada and he
was in Hong Kong that incident that
experience just gave me so much pain
when you have enough pain then your
motivation I said to myself I never ever
ever want to live there like that again
whatever it takes I don't want to
experience so helpless that I couldn't
do anything
in order to protect my family in order
just have the freedom the ability to to
buy a plane ticket I need money I need
money when if you want your kids suffer
when your wife needs money when your
family needs money Buddha is going to
help them if it's not you and you don't
get to that point
but what kind of man are we the prize
isn't out there the gold isn't out there
the you know cheapen isn't out there
it's here it's inside and when it comes
down to for me is yes finding the why
and at the same time enjoying the
process too many people have a goal to
go out and get rich and drive fancy cars
and buy the brand-new amazing house
built from scratch custom-built house
and I'll do anything to get there I'll
do whatever crap you want me to do as
long as I get that outcome and that's
the wrong way to go about things if you
look at the most successful people we've
heard this again how many times from
actors to entrepreneurs and inventors
across the board people enjoy the work
there is no end goal you love the
process of what you're doing and you can
only force yourself to do something for
so long before you give up on it like
that outcome that goal isn't strong
enough for you to deal with all of this
crap that you have to go through instead
recognize that the real the real benefit
is you doing work that you love you're
doing work that you can pour your heart
and soul and energy into you're doing
something that you're so proud of that
you want to show off to your parents and
to your grandkids and save it for future
generations they look what I mean look
what I was a part of but what I built
having that kind of pride and passion
and pouring it into the work instead of
just mailing it in and doing what the
customer wants and just kind of barely
getting by blow people away create
something that people when they look at
it's so spectacular and so different and
so new that I've never seen it before
because you have invested so much of
your art into making it come to fruition
that's where people when they tap into
their genius level talent and apply it
that's when they start to see massive
success with you're just doing what
people are asking you and doing the bare
minimum and just getting by then you're
just gonna get by and life as well and
your business is just gonna get by as
well stop having so many external
focuses and focus on why you're doing
this and making something that you can
be proud of and enjoying not every
single moment of every single day you're
gonna have down parts in your business
and in life but net-net enjoying the
process the creation I
making these videos if I was doing it
just to try to get to a million
subscribers I would have quit a long
time ago
I love Wednesday this is my filming day
I come in I'm looking forward to it all
week I love coming here and talking to
you guys I'm making these videos for you
it's for you and it's for me I love the
process and as long as I love it I'm
gonna keep doing it and the second that
I stopped loving it
the second that I lose interest like
uh-oh I got to go in and film again it's
over I'll quit and go do something else
because you will never do great things
when you don't have a great mindset and
attitude that you're pointing to the
work to create it anytime I put
something in the world
I am always connecting to an idea I'm
always asked why am I making this what
why I'm putting this out in the world
why so with with concussion dr. Bennet
Omalu was deeply connected to tell the
truth and he said that truth doesn't
have a side and that's what he kept
saying I thought that was such a
powerful if any idea that there you know
whose side are you on you're Republican
or Democrat I'm trying to tell the truth
truth the truth doesn't have a side I
think Mark Zuckerberg said it
brilliantly at Harvard he was saying
that finding your purpose isn't enough
you have to help other people find this
and I know you're passionate about this
whatever that definition is but it has
to lead everyone so if I'm whether I
meet a celebrity and entrepreneur or
whether I meet somebody starting out I'm
always asking them a question how can
you use what you have to make a
difference in the life of other people
yeah because if you start there
everything else will work out but if
you're starting from the point of what
am I gonna get then you're always gonna
feel disconnected and I see that I see
people who live like that and feel pain
in their lives every day I see that it's
not like some conceptual philosophy we
see it I see people who are only in it
for themselves and they feel
disconnected dissatisfied every single
day and then you see the other extreme
where people are just trying to give too
much more than they even have themselves
and they also feel disconnected and
again nothing wrong
thing at all right so we know again
attachment and aversion to sides of the
same coin mm-hmm so we want to be in
that dynamic balance of growth but
always to give yeah so I always think
how can I go three steps deeper so that
I can move three steps forward so I can
give three times as much right so that's
always my mentality how do I go deeper
to go more forward to give more yeah and
if I can get those and three in action
for that reason see it's what about the
reasoning you could do anything you like
but it's why are you doing it another
person not only do you have to move from
point A to B in life but point a is
often a very difficult place to be
because we're fragile and bounded and
mortal and limited and because we know
that and so one of the implications of
that as many great religious traditions
are at pains to illustrate or
demonstrate or proclaim is that life is
essentially suffering and I believe that
to be a fundamental truth but but
perhaps not the most fundamental truth
because I think the most fundamental
truth is that despite the fact that life
is suffering people can transcend that
and partly the way they transcend that
is by pursuing things of value and so
that if there is no value proposition at
hand then you have no meaning to justify
the difficult conditions of your life
and that's brutally difficult for people
no Nietzsche said he who has a why can
bear anyhow and you see and I've
certainly seen this as a clinical
practitioner that people who have no
purpose in their life are embittered by
the difficulties of their life and they
become first bitter and then resentful
and then revengeful and then cruel and
there's plenty of places to go past
cruel that's just where you start if
you're really on a downhill path a lot
of people don't ask themselves why yeah
do I want more cars more jets and so
that no I don't all right speaking of
mr. Cuban I I go to Dallas one day and
I'm you know I'm like man mark I never
I've never been in your office man tell
me about it's the man's all kind of
thing it was huge probably right uh and
does and he was like alright I'll meet
you and then he comes to the hotel in
his pajamas and this is one sidekicks
without looking at his sidekick and I
why am I gonna I mean I said I want to
go your office he said I haven't been in
three years so what do you mean you
haven't been the office in three years
he said what am i what do I want more
money he said I wanted to chill home
with my son to jakester I want to answer
my things here I but I'm like but why do
you publicly give out your email if you
don't want more work he's like I enjoy
sitting at home in my pajamas looking at
this stuff and I ain't know and I
realize you know he's just like me why
are you doing things you have to ask
yourself right and that is your
discipline right why am I going to work
every single day and of course I
understand a lot of people here don't
have the luxury like I am afforded now
and you have to go to work
you have to you have to keep the lights
on and all this kumbaya crap about just
do it for love is [ __ ] the end of
the day if you got to keep the lights on
right or there's a crack but but but uh
you got to ask yourself why the piece of
advice that I always give to somebody
whether it's an entrepreneur or somebody
who wants to be the greatest parent of
all time what is your goal you've got to
start with your goal everything works
backwards from that Simon and I did a
video that essentially broke the
internet about Millennials somebody
watched it
what got Simon on the world stage is
this whole concept of why you've got to
know why you're doing what you're doing
if you're just showing up every day to
cut and dye hair to keep your lights on
you're gonna have far less energy to
make it through the hard times than
somebody who is there to help transform
somebody to help make somebody their
best to help them feel their best and I
hope that you guys saw that video not
too long ago of the hairdresser that
went around and he was doing makeovers
on homeless people right then
it was incredible it was so beautiful
the look on their face at that moment
where they see themselves for the first
time in front of the mirror and they are
seeing something totally new they're
seeing a version of themselves that they
did not know was there and the ability
to give that gift like it is so easy to
get lost in the day-to-day grind of what
you do what any of us do but if at the
core I view is a deep and unending why
for what you're doing you've got
something now you've got a chance to
transcend what you're doing and the way
that happens is very tactical has
nothing to do with like whoo being down
there it's none of that you're gonna
have the energy that you need to fight
through
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Quentin Tarantino on finding your
why's that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
answer the questions in the comments
below here we go question number one
what is your why number two how will you
put your why into action and number
three what will you do when your why get
stuff
before I ever made a movie when I was
thinking about the movies I wanted to
make one of the I don't even think i
100% knew what my aesthetic was then but
I knew I wanted to be part of this and I
wanted to make a contribution and the
closest thing that I knew about what I
wanted to do was I remember thinking I
want to make movies that people will
watch them and that will make them want
to make movies yeah well that that
worked and that actually ended up kind
of working and there was this that neat
aspect and I think it sort of Coast you
know coinciding with Mike you know with
my career and the rise of the
independent film movement in general in
the 90s that there was this aspect that
I actually think that young people were
in decades earlier they might have
picked up a guitar and started a garage
band they actually felt that they could
express themselves more by trying to
make a movie yeah and I think that ended
up kind of happening to some degree or
another if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you up or that would be collect a
little beacon if you liked this video
check it to believe life video we did on
finding your why I think you're gonna
enjoy it and find it helpful with the
link is right there next to me you need
to believe and I'll see you there
everybody has a wife passion is the
feeling you have that you would probably
do this for free